federal regulators are warning airlines
about a potentially dangerous issue
affecting a handful of Boeing passenger
planes the FAA and Boeing say faulty
sensors on new 737 max jets can cause
the plane to go into a steep dive the
warning comes just over a week after a
Boeing 737 max plane crash in Indonesia
killing all 189 people on board Kris Van
Cleave reports the FAA is emergency
action orders Airlines to ensure 737 max
pilots are properly trained in the event
the plane goes into an uncommanded dive
similar to what lion Air flight 610
experienced before crashing last week
this is pretty significant Chris Ross
aimer is a retired airline captain who
flew an older version of the 737 I'm
actually surprised that the FA didn't
ground these max the aircraft because
when they issue an ad as you mentioned
that's an emergency situation the
horizontal stabilizer are those small
wings just below the tail flaps at the
rear known as the elevator can trim or
adjust the angle of the planes nose up
or down if the sensors that help control
the trim malfunction the 737 max could
automatically put itself into a dive
forcing pilots to react quickly to
override that system and pull up if you
let it continuously trim trim trim trim
trim trim trim trim so it's gonna happen
pretty fast
it could happen very fast yes the FAA
estimates 245 of the new 737 max Jets
are in use worldwide 49 are currently
flown by three US carriers there have
been no reports of malfunctioning
sensors on 737 max planes in the u.s.
early indications from the recovered
flight data recorder in Indonesia show
that sensor had malfunctioned on the
planes three previous flights leading up
to Lion Air 610 s crash the airline
maintained a mechanical issue was fixed
prior to the doomed flight we don't know
exactly what happened at I cockpit did I
actually get a runaway stabiliser if
they did why didn't they immediately
correct it and take care of it Boeing
called it's bulletin part of its usual
process however
it is unusual for a directive like this
to be issued for a brand new type of
airliner aviation experts tell CBS News
this kind of malfunction alone should
not have resulted in a crash adding US
airline pilots practice for this type of
issue for CBS this morning Saturday Kris
Van Cleave Washington Chris thank you